The APIs provided by LRVM, are designed to remove an important pin point for
system developers, namely system crashes. We know,
that system crashes can come from software errors
as well as from power failure. That brings up an interesting thought experiment.
Which is what we're going to discuss next. So how does LRVM do it? Well, it does
it by providing transaction synaptics for
persistent data structures. It calls itself lightweight
since it eliminates all the usual heavyweight
properties associated with transactions, which are usually
called acid properties. And LRVM makes
transactions light weight, for use precisely for
the intended purpose which is recovery management.
In LRVM, changes to virtual memory are
written as re-do logs, at the end of
a transaction. And these re-do logs are forced to
the disk at the end of the transaction as
common records Of changes made to virtual memory. And
as it log force that happens at commit point
is what is called a synchronist IO, because the
application has to wait for the IO to complete
before proceeding with further execution. So implementation, a precise
implementation of the transaction semantics of LRVM requires a log force to the
disk to make sure that the redo log that represents all of the changes made to
virtual memory Within that critical section bound
by, a begin transaction, end transaction is
actually committed and persisted on the disk.
It is precisely for this reason namely synchronous
IO, that transactions are considered heavy weight,
even though the synantics of transactions have
been considerably reduced and made simpler in
the design of LRVM. In other words,
for a precise implementation of LRVM, at the commit point, it requires at least
one synchronous disk I/O. The system design
tend to avoid transaction despite the precise semantics
of transaction due to the time penalty associated
with disk I/O. If disk I/O can be
eliminated, then transactions would be cheap. And if
transactions become cheap then everyone will use it and
life is good. Rio Vista, the lesson that
we're going to review now, asks the question, "How
can we eliminate synchronous disk I/O?" So in
other words, Rio Vista is going towards a performance-conscious
design and implementation of persistent memory
starting from where LRVM left off.